all right phil we're gonna put 30
seconds on the clock and let's see how
many meals
you can raise by making some putts ready
three two
one go
[Applause]
these are ten foot putts it's just
automatic
oh come on a thousand meals
every putt he makes is 10 000 meals
that is incredible let's go phil let's
go that's incredible
10 seconds left 80 000 meals 90
000 meals 100 000 meals
phil's ready for this two one
wow that's unbelievable 150
[Applause]
the current holder of the water maker
trophy the pga championship winner
six-time major champion phil mickelson
remember modified alternate shot you
take swing big boy that's t-shot go from
there
i'm just slow playing it here because i
keep thinking they're going to give it
to me but they're not
really not all right baby
that's good that's good cool
pretty good yeah all right driver it's
in the fairway there so
all right that is gonna be
perfect to get you some of that there
bryson okay let's see nice drive you're
gonna have to hit it to catch it though
true
oh oh it's the master good job
kind of like that cheyenne that's kind
of what i was trying to articulate
at the hill oh here it comes let it pick
up a little pace as it comes back down
oh thank you oh my goodness and then
give my man a putt
all right phil dude come on to the moon
long drive
challenge let's track this one with top
tracer presented by capital one
oh man he's out here sean you can go get
some of that that's pretty good hey
yeah there's some problems thank you you
see did you see the balance on the
downslope now here it's tumbling
on national tv with a 51 year old out
driving it can't happen
like i can't have that it's not okay
oh whoa oh no
oh no you dummy
stay fair way left hang on
yeah nice drive
money man thanks parker we bought the
same length as the donations
15 in a row
the match great competition great
camaraderie
and raising a lot of money so now
mickelson
and brady two down with three to play
at the par 3 16.
come on come on
come on oh
shoot shut up keep calling it's okay
good shot is it moving
yeah it's moving come on keep coming
good job dude
terrific trying to wheel that thing down
there